remember that stylish yellow jumpsuit
Bruce Lee wore in the 1972 film Game of
Death it can be yours for a starting bid
of around 30-thousand US dollars one of
more than a dozen items up for grabs at
an auction of memorabilia this week in
Hong Kong it's all part of a collection
that Lee apparently gave to his friend
and former student taka Kimura who in
our time of life you know really no
Bruce Lee in person or seeing him wear
that or use that or whatever so it's
difficult so if I get a letter of
authenticity from kaki Kimura I believe
in that that's all I care for you know
and anybody else they can say any they
can say whatever they want everything
from clothing to props go under the
hammer tonight including an autographed
Fist of Fury brochure a jade pendant and
nunchucks but there is a heavy dose of
skepticism among Bruce Lee loyalists who
say this memorabilia is fake and y'all
fighting upon Jack I found some of the
items I've already worn the auction
house that some of the items are very
questionable okay I think there's a
chance they're fake basically I know
some of the items are fake at first
glance it's impossible they are Bruce
Lee's relics jur become I think of items
as fake as these can be picked out for
this auction why should I go see and buy
them despite lingering questions about
authenticity those 14 items are on
auction Thursday in a sale that could
stretch into the millions it is a
reminder that even 40 years after his
death here Bruce Lee remains one of Hong
Kong's favorite sons Zeb Eckert
Bloomberg